let's go next to our caller from the
eight one four area code caller from
eight one four who's this where are you
calling from
hey David this is Sam can you hear me
yes go ahead
excellent I'm calling from New Orleans
and I have a silly question and a
serious question okay
silly question is did you hear - Sam
Harris has changed his podcast name from
waking up to making sense no I did not I
think it's just a funny official switch
from talking about it my stuff which is
what originally honey traps me - its
podcast to creating logic and make money
which is uh I just think a real fun
change there but that's a silly question
serious question story from a little
narrative I'm a film college and I'm
actually finally making a little bit of
money which is pretty cool but the more
I watch YouTube things the more I care
about politics the more that I want to
like you know find a way to do camera
work for democracy now make a little
documentary do you have any advice for
people in my situation that I have
cameras and want to do you know good
stories for the world as opposed to just
make a commercial I wish I did I mean
what I did is I just started my own
thing with the cameras that that I
bought and built a platform and that's
what I've been doing for more than 10
years I have no idea how someone would
go about just getting hired I mean I
have no connections at Democracy Now I
have no clue whether they're hiring or
not there's a couple approaches you can
take one is you do something on spec
meaning you just do it without making
any money from it with the idea that you
could then make money from it in the
future or use it to get a job somewhere
right that's one approach the other idea
would be that you basically do two
things at once you you work some regular
thing which is how you make money and
then you forget about making money from
the stuff that you like doing and you do
it because you like it and because you
think it's important but you know it's
it's it's not a high success rate thing
to be able to make a living from the
media activism that you want to do I
feel like I've been incredibly lucky and
timing and a lot of other things are
responsible for it but I wish I had at
least more optimistic advice hey well
it's still great to listen to you and I
appreciate what you do sorry
a little more than I expected on the
call but that's okay you did great li
glad to be a listener thank you hey
thank you so much David appreciate the
call thank you so much